o lote pessoa de quem fosse o autarca e
outro que o início do speedy muito
rápida - podemos dizer que este vídeo
foi agora se e cuba liga e nós vamos
jogar o tabuleiro ouija e eu tenho e
meio dessas coisas mas acredito que vou
fazer e fingir que o tabuleiro e álbum
she mesmo eu não sabia nada eu fui para
a casa de banho só um giro que coisa ok
pessoal já estamos aqui prontos para
cumprir o ritual aqui o tabuleiro já
está pronto é lei até que a câmara
estava em outro lado fala que está tudo
escuro mas tipo nem fora ainda tem uma
janela aberta que eu não consiga para
portanto dentro um pouco mas eu acho que
não interfere mais preparado que
explanam superaeroporto olha aí olha
aqui por tudo isso assim isso não pode
não acender daí
agora eu acho que temos que colocar aqui
um dedo esclarecem melhor na minha
orelha eu acho que a primeira pergunta é
se perguntar se há alguma coisa tá aqui
perto nós não é doleiro cuja existe
alguma indignado por normal perto de nós
puto não brinque com isto é de outubro
em casa no mês mesmo é brincar brincar e
sentir esse cheiro e só estou tremendo
canalha rádio não diz o the bee não
tinham que tirar isso ir bem canal do
tabuleiro ouija exista alguma entidade
por anormal perto de nós
não vai acontecer nada nesta domingo eu
acho que se eu dormir para assumir outro
igual charlie charlie tabuleiro ouija
será quente da adepará norma gostar
cuidar da tiveram vai responder né
se não está a dormir na hora
gosto de brincar com isso não tem o que
falar brinca porque não tem que brigar
tomar cuidado ao falar sério para
conhecer tudo o que há para com essa
menina você não fui eu e minhas irmãs e
sutil que todo primeiro por dentro e
tommi makinen tabuleiro ouija existe
alguma coisa nesta sala alguma coisa
paranormal alguma coisa paranormal 2
paranormal mesmo eu torci estupidez não
resulta assim existe alguma coisa para
normal neste estúdio para bater o
turismo futuro não sou eu
juro pela minha mãe por ter no seu todo
chile só eu vou ter de dar mole legal aí
o meu eu acho que a gente não veio para
brincar com isto cabelo vídeo manhã em
trípoli a melhor área para para parar e
já tá comendo junto tabuleiro ícaro leva
chumbo e postá-la faca tabuleiro william
joyce uso de drogas para regiões onde só
vai ficar conosco
olha só o tal tipo de estudo
eu sou eu vou para aí bairro tudo assim
ele não subiu o juro nunca tirou daqui
porque ajuda porque ajuda melhor deles
não queria lembo 152 [ __ ] para brincar
com juju futuro porto de não brincar com
essas merdas a sério porque não quer
brincar mas desta vez em uma década ao
futuro por tudo muito a sério
juro por tudo portanto companhia não que
eu não brinco mais e chegou também à
margem da marcha mais popular o ija esta
presença é masculina ou feminina
não vamos sair agora já não toma o
primeiro assim tanto agora me senti uma
hora para hora portanto por que você
quer para para [ __ ] para já não falar
mesmo assim ele não tinha isso como é
que está o cheiro não sair não sai de lá
estavas borrada que estava a viver
tabuleiro ouija paranormal ficaram quem
vem lá em casa ver tabuleiro ouija
existe algum método novos aqui perto não
mas não estou tremendo canal não há
outra maneira eu não mexe a cimpor não
sai porque eu não mexo assim olha aí
talvez rever apaga uma seqüência normal
custa [ __ ] paga semana no qual era o
rosto
tudo isso eu não tô aqui falando bem
podiam sentar eu já tentei então falta
só aí por toda aí por toda aí pô tu
ponto podre tudo maravilhoso estou assim
vai
foi assim que nos olha só que eu não sou
estrela da época eu não tô brincando de
ter o efeito protetor da pessoa que está
comigo porque eu fui fazer crânio
o tamanho para qualquer ali não vai
cooperar e rafael [ __ ] porto vai para
o [ __ ]
[ __ ] se preocupado contigo
mas como saber que estava a mexer porque
era operário estava quase a chorar
[ __ ] que estava fazendo chorar é
compatível com o tempo cada um olha para
aquilo que nós por cima estava mal ao
corpo também foi esclarecer melhor o
envio de um outro veículo pode levar meu
querido mas só muito fashion tv e puxa a
água pois não fazem nada igual mas o
chato não serei só eu que construí
espero que tenham gostado já sabe quanto
com vocês aqui favorito e é lanterna
ainda faz isso